et ce n'est pas fini avec nous ce soir
fabrice arfi bonsoir merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation co responsable
du pôle enquête à mediapart
on vient de l'apprendre la cheffe du
groupe de sécurité de matignon a
démissionné pour écarter toute polémique
dit elle quelle est votre réaction ce
sens ben je suis affligé je vois pas ce
que cette personne à avoir avec la faire
et je trouve que c'est tout à fait
honorable de sa part de démissionner
pour éviter la polémique
mais elle est une sorte de victimes
collatérales d'une fiction juridique
créée par le parquet de paris
main dans la main avec le pouvoir
exécutif exécutif pardon sur lequel nous
enquêtons et qui tous deux viennent les
idiots utiles de monsieur betala dans
cette affaire qui veut agité la thèse du
complot de l'état contre l'état de je ne
sais quel barbouzeries le seul sujet de
la sphère benalla c'est monsieur bennane
à la présidence de la république le seul
sujet de la sphère benalla concernant
l'ingérence russe et le fait que le
parquet national financiers a ouvert une
enquête pour corruption comme nous
venons de l'annoncer sur mediapart
pour l'histoire de ce contrat nous et
pendant que monsieur mais dallas était à
l'elysée avec un oligarque proches de
monsieur poutine est liée selon
plusieurs magistrats européens à la
mafia les enregistrements n'est pas un
délit n'est pas un objet criminel en soi
c'est par les enregistrements qui sont
le problème c'est le contenu des
enregistrements et on voit bien que là
nous sommes dans un moment inédit dans
l'histoire du journalisme c'est inédit
ce qui s'est passé bien et bien nous
avons un journal qui s'appelle valeurs
actuelles qui posent des questions à
matignon ces questions sont démenties
par matignon
donc ce ne sont pas des informations
font des rumeurs c'est rien d'ailleurs
le directeur de cabinet parle monsieur
edouard philippaerts d'allégations ce
rire plusieurs reprises la reprise ce
rien et transmis au parquet de paris
c'est tellement rien de valeur actuelle
n'en fait pas d'article mais le parquet
de paris lui ouvre une enquête ouvre une
enquête pour atteinte à la vie privée
dont personne ne se plaint il ya un
fantôme dans ce pays on sait pas qui
c'est il n'existe pas mais on pense que
sa vie privée a été violée en tout cas
le procureur de paris pense qu'il a que
sa vie privée a été violée et la
première le premier acte d' enquête de
sept de cette enquête préliminaire qui
n'a pas de base légale
d'envoyer des procureurs et la brigade
criminelle je dis bien la brigade
criminelle perquisitionné médiapart
racontez-nous temps mots ce qui s'est
passé exactement vous y étiez oui
j'étais elle n'était pas là mais vous
maintenant edwy plenel déposée au
tribunal dans la sphère beau pas avec
nos avocats et alors que la conférence
de rédaction du lundi est la plus
importante de la semaine à mediapart
toucher à sa fin on nous parlions
d'ailleurs ça s'invente pas des dérives
liberticides dénoncer ici ou là du
régime macron que ce soit sur le droit
d'informer ou sur le droit de manifester
sonne à la porte
un procureur deux procureurs et trois
policiers dont un commissaire
divisionnaire de la brigade criminelle
qui m'annonce puisque c'est moi qui les
accueillent monsieur c'est une
perquisition
voilà donc comme le droit nous y
autorise j'ai évidemment empêché la
médiation vous le savez je connais tout
ça on enquête préliminaire sans un
mandat d'un juge des libertés et de la
détention on peut refuser j'ai refusé
parce qu'évidemment une perquisition
dans une rédaction c'est une atteinte
manifeste au secret des sources
et si nous on n'a plus de source pas
vous le public tout le monde plus
personne là ma formation
ou alors on devient des attachés présent
vous le voyez comme une tentative
d'intimidation des journalistes des
sources comment faire c'est de
l'intimidation c'est une entrave à la
liberté d'informer il est dit de ce
point de vue là puisque l'origine de
cette enquête ce qui a provoqué cette
enquête c'est le pouvoir exécutif sur
lequel nous enquêtons sur la fois non
pas de la transmission d'un soupçon d'un
délit sur la foi de la transmission de
questions de presse démenties par
matignon sur rien on a bâti du vent sur
du sable pour aller perquisitionné un
journal et aujourd'hui on alimente cette
thèse du complot avec une chef de la
sécurité de monsieur edouard philippe
qui démissionnent qui n'a rien à voir ni
de près ni de loin dans ses affaires
d'enregistrement pour le bonheur de qui
de celui qui est tranquille aujourd'hui
qui s'appelle monsieur benalla dont nous
avons révélé qu'il a violé son contrôle
judiciaire ce qui fait qu'ils risquent
la détention provisoire dont nous avoir
révélé qu'il a menti parjurer devant le
sénat où nous nous trouvons nous nous
avons révélé depuis plusieurs semaines
qu'il est lié pendant qu'il est est
habilité secret défense à l'elysée à un
oligarque russe richissime proche du
président d'une puissance étrangère et
non des moindres vladimir
poutine et qu'il a dissimulé des preuves
qu'il a opéré des destructions de
preuves comme c'est ce qui ressort des
enregistrements que nous avions révélé
et alors j'ai l'impression vous réduisez
la sphère abena là mais beaucoup
soupçonnent des complicités de l'elysée
est maintenant des complicités de
matignon que benalla étaient protégés à
quoi se sont à message avait des
solutions cela voulait évidemment on
avance plus on vous nomme évidemment que
l'histoire de la sphère benalla c'est
l'histoire d'une impunité que lui a
offert le sommet de l'état il n'y a pas
de doute là dessus mais c'est l'elysée
l'homme qui demande au mois de novembre
que le lier une complaisance de la
justice pour pour pour monsieur benalla
c'est le président de la république
c'est emmanuel macron l'homme qui défend
benalla le 24 juillet à la maison de
l'amérique latine c'est emmanuel macron
qui s'en prend à la justice qui met en
cause le travail du parlement et qui dit
que nous avons une presse qui ne cherche
plus la vérité
l'homme qui a pu se déplacer avec des
passeports diplomatiques sans que ni le
ministère de l'intérieur ni le quai
d'orsay ne fasse semblant de s'en rendre
compte
c'est monsieur benalla donc la sphère
benalla est évidemment une affaire aux
atours d'affaires d'état est bien plus
qu'une affaire de l'état notamment
puisque nous sommes face aujourd'hui à
une question d'ingérences russe
potentiel pendant qu'il était à l'elysée
qu'il était par fonction dépositaire des
secrets de la présidence de la
république et on a créé un rideau de
fumée juridique une fiction juridique un
rien juridique par le parquet de paris
est plutôt par le procureur de la
république de paris rémy l emirates que
vous mettez en cause bien sûr puisque
c'est lui qui ouvre cette enquête pour
atteinte à la vie privée dont personnes
seules se plaint sur la foi d'un
courrier de matignon qui n'est même pas
une dénonciation de la soupe du
l'existence d'un délit sur rien imaginez
que à chaque fois qu'un milk un journal
pose des questions à un ministère on va
maintenant faire transmettre les
questions au parquet de paris qui va
envoyer la brigade criminelle et des
procureurs perquisitionné mediapart
mais je veux dire de téléspectateurs
comprennent bien c'est à dire que pour
vous rémy heitz est aux ordres de
l'exécutif à bâle en fin de toute façon
le procureur de la république en france
sont soumis hiérarchiquement au pouvoir
pour l'intégrer il ya une particularité
dans la nomination de monsieur ait c'est
qu'il est arrivé à ce poste après que
les prédécesseurs qui lui avait été
choisi
par madame b loubet la garde des sceaux
par le conseil supérieur de la
magistrature et même par matignon à
l'époque a été rayé d'un trait de plume
par le fait du prince
en l'occurrence par monsieur macro qui
préférait qui voulait son procureur à
savoir aimé y ait mêmes edouard philippe
qui est derrière l' enquête qui a été à
l'origine de notre tentative de critique
de perquisition avait déclaré en octobre
dernier au journal le monde qu'il
voulait être certain qu'ils allaient se
sentir bien avec le nouveau procureur
celui auquel ils envoient des questions
de valeurs actuelles et qui a et au bout
du compte il ya une perquisition à
médiapart pourquoi pourquoi pour trouver
nos sources
la seule justification de cette enquête
préliminaire c'est traquer les sources
d'un journal qui publie des informations
qui embête le pouvoir en place
c'est la seule justification sur la foi
d'un habillage juridique qu'aujourd'hui
des juristes des avocats et même des
magistrats contestent
merci beaucoup fabrice arfi ni survenue
réagir à chaud à ses toutes dernières
informations concernant la sphère
benalla je rappelle que vous êtes co
responsable du pôle enquête à mediapart
merci infiniment